when we talk about language
we often dig down to universal
categories like nouns and verbs
consonants and vowels phrases and
sentences we end up with these cross
language concepts that individual
languages are built on almost as if the
colorful diversity found in the world's
languages is just icing on the strong
unity of the linguistic cake and
language is grounded in our way of
thinking and processing information
which is itself universal among humans
so languages and cultures are
superficial but language and cognition
run deep but this isn't the only way to
look at language what if the language we
are brought up to speak actually relates
to the way we look at reality from this
perspective a language is a particular
way of conceptualizing the world and has
close ties to culture in the 1930s
Benjamin Lee Whorf talked about language
this way
he argued that different languages
represent different ways of thinking
about the world around us this view has
come to be called linguistic relativity
exploring the grammar of the Hopi
language he concluded that they Hopi
have an entirely different concept of
time than European languages do and that
the European concepts of time and matter
are actually conditioned by language
itself
one practical consequence of linguistic
relativity direct translation between
languages isn't always possible since
Hopi and English aren't simply ways of
expressing the same thing in different
words you can't actually preserve
thoughts or viewpoints when you
translate between them in its strongest
expression linguistic relativity the
idea that viewpoints vary from language
to language relies on linguistic
determinism the idea that language
determines thought in other words how
people think doesn't just vary depending
on their language but is actually
grounded in determined by the specific
language of their community linguistic
relativity has been abandoned and
criticized over the decades with critics
aiming to show that perception and
cognition are universal not tied to
language and culture but some
psychologists and anthropologists
continue to argue that differences in a
languages structure and words may play a
role in determining how we think
experiments on how speakers of different
languages approach non-linguistic tasks
continue to spark this debate thank you
for joining me on this quick tour of
linguistic relativity and linguistic
determinism please hit the subscribe
button if you'd like to keep on learning
with me
you